pendant 3 jours les militaires ont
troqué leur uniforme contre un maillot
de basket à l'occasion des championnats
de France militaire la deuxè édition
était organisé cette année au gymnase
malmedon de morpa les matchs ont opposé
les équipes de l'armée de terre de l'air
la marine et la gendarmerie c'est les
meilleurs joueurs des sélections de la
gendarmerie de la Marine nationale de
l'armée de l'air et de l'armée de terre
qui sont sélectionnés on fait des stages
pour les détecter et après on les
sélectionne pour venir participer au
championnat trans militaire à POS bon
dunk une centaine de joueurs venus de
toute la France ont fait le show pendant
ces 3 jours de compétition c'est un
tournoi qui me tient beaucoup à cœur
parce que ça me permet bah non seulement
voilà de profiter de jouer au basket
dans le cadre du travail c'est c'est
génial et et en plus de pouvoir échanger
avec toutes les autres équipe où je
connais évidemment la plupart des
basketteurs et à chaque fois c'est un
vrai un vrai plaisir de retrouver tous
mes camarades on m'a contater et j'ai
saisi l'occasion je pense que j'en
aurais pas 50 occasions comme ça de
partager ces moment l'année dernière moi
j étais pas je suis nouvelle cette année
et oui oui c'est très très sympa
l'ambiance est vraiment sympa et la
mentalité très sympa aussi l'équipe de
la Marine a remporté la finale contre
l'armée de l'air sur le score de 62 à 55
les meilleurs joueurs du tournoi seront
sélectionnés par le staff de l'équipe de
France militaire pour participer au
championnat du monde de la catégorie la
compétition sera organisée au mois de
juillet à San Diego aux
États-Unis